hey this is Eddie Pepitone from pep
talks and we want to welcome a sponsor
parachute sheets parachute it's an
online betting brand based in Venice
Beach and they mailed me a set of sheets
and it was great it really was and you
know I wouldn't advertise anything that
wasn't cool and parachute has created a
line of everyday betting essentials from
sheets to duvet comforter comforters to
give you superior sleep now they're
bedding is made of 100-percent long
staple Egyptian cotton manufactured in a
mill in Tuscany that's been weaving
betting for nearly 80 years and then
shipped to your door and a parachute
cuts out the licensing and distribution
fee so you can experience high quality
bedding for less and parachute also
gives back in a big way they partner
with the United Nations Foundation
nothing but nets campaign to deliver
life-saving malaria prevention bed nets
to those in need so you can go to
parachute home calm / pep use promo code
pep and parachute will give you twenty
five dollars off on your first order
okay so it's a really cool product the
website is really cool on the product
comes in this really cool box are the
quality the betting for me was really
great um it was just a really good sleep
experience and you can read about on
they do some cool things day on there
they have a blog blog parachute home
calm and they talk about how thread
count is a marketing gimmick and anyway
I really like this product so please I
go do it use a pep on parachute home
calm use promo code pep and you will get
twenty five dollars off on your first
order
hey everybody welcome to pep talks with
the bitter Buddha Eddie Pepitone and I
know what you're thinking already he's
got a nickname I he must be incredible
by the way what you hear in my voice is
the fact that I don't want to be doing
the podcasts I've been told to do them
by my by my team and you know I think
you all know that team Pepitone well
let's just leave it at that look here's
some dates I will be in Atlanta at the
Laughing Skull September 24 through 27
then I'm going to be at the Orlando
indie comedy festival october third
vancouver i'm at the rickshaw theatre on
october 17th and then peoria i'm at the
juke juke box comedy club october 22 to
24 you can get tickets at Eddie Pepitone
calm and uh well that's it that's it for
me um you have listened to Ono right we
have a guest today I am sorry we have a
guest and my guest this week is a
stand-up and writer he writes and is
requiring on marin on ifc which i have
been on ah you heard him on his old
podcast walking the room and his new
podcast very popular i asked a very good
friend of mine a comedian guy said what
do you think of the dollop and he said
it's [ __ ] good the dollop is the name
of his podcast please welcome Dave
Anthony thank you it a is it Eddie haha
Oh what happened we what's that noise
glitch oh don't though I'm touching that
thing oh just forget that happened well
then why you got stuff sticking out that
i can grab bread why do you have it what
is why is it here what a shitty
operation i realized this is my network
but what uh yes this is your network um
hey buddy i was gonna make comments
about what you said and now I've
forgotten everything
look you're about as interested in life
as I am that's how we that's how we were
late yeah oh for sure like we both know
that it's it's a world not of our own
making no and even though you've done
pretty good you have a kid I defecate I
made a person but that's not hard to do
I know but it's hard to keep them alive
I think it's hard no no not even them
alike but keep everything intact like
I'd not totally [ __ ] them up not totally
[ __ ] which who knows I don't know if
you're doing that and I I haven't really
doing pretty well yeah he seems okay but
to hold together you know marriage kid
then working on your career as well
that's uh that is that's adult stuff it
is adult stuff it really is and so it's
funny because comedians suppose
supposedly you know and by the way this
is the rap such is for sure I wasn't
sure I thought it was an interrogation I
just caught myself you know what happens
on these podcasts folks is that you have
to fill an hour and so I saw an opening
to like talk about something like being
an adult and also the juxtaposition or
the paradox of a comedian is supposed to
be a silly silly guy that's that's
that's the view of most comedians I
think tell me you Joe told me a joke and
I feel like saying to them here's a joke
for you I can barely live comedy this is
a joke for you once you tell this at
your family dinner [ __ ] you [ __ ]
tell is it your Thanksgiving dinner I
get up flailing for God flailing for
anything sure just something to grasp on
to this la fenix at how make this make
sense why is this turkey here ah but
isn't it true though I mean you you're
running an adult life Hank it oh and how
is it going you look good you look good
thank you I'm tired um I guess I'm
guess I'm uh yeah yeah I don't really
think of it that way I just you don't
you know yeah you don't think about I
mean I still laugh because right I still
have days free right i mean when I'm not
working on Marin I'm still just [ __ ]
around all day ro I mean I'm working a
lot writing but but yeah it's not what
are you writing um I this dollop takes a
long time to work on every week but yeah
i'm writing pilots yeah and and things
of that nature so let me ask you this
because I'm always fascinated by because
I have a tremendous lack of discipline
would know you don't even have to say
hahahaha it shows in my in my wardrobe
for sure today I'm wearing I decided
today to go with sweatpants because I
mean I like a change I like when you
come in wearing finally get to see you
wearing something loose and I folks if
you haven't seen me I usually dress up
like a fine English gentleman i am told
to Stephen Fry of Los Angeles but now I
am starting to loosen up a little bit
early he's letting he's letting us Eddie
down as we're say I'm letting my free
it's heady right it is that okay is that
the enemy is there and you're Dave Dave
Anthony I was given an info she thought
you were that's getting weird tell me
what the dollop now the fact that you
work hard on it also is I should
backtrack disciplining yourself to light
is it like okay get the kid how old is
your kid is six so get him to school yep
he's out of the house and boom do you go
right to writing no I go on Twitter and
I make fun of people yeah and then you'd
like to by the way I was looking at your
Twitter feed today in preparation oh god
that's a bad thing to do and you what
you do and I don't do this because what
I do is just put out I also saw that you
don't be I was fired by the way that is
a funny thing when you thought I follow
well it is a funny thing well when thing
is is I follow a lot of people but I
never look at the feed except my feed
and who has responded to me so it
doesn't mean a lot to follow someone I
don't think accept it jacks up their
numbers a little bit the only sometimes
I'll
all of someone if they're annoying you
yeah like if kick in large is screaming
at MSNBC and I'll unfollow him for a day
or two and then I'll go back and foam so
you might have been doing something I
don't know Mom but because I thought I
followed you or I just don't like what
you do it could be I sometimes don't
like what I do because Twitter no no
Twitter Facebook in that [ __ ] like what
happened and I was i I get very strident
I'm particularly strident about like
being like I'll just wake up and be so
pissed at certain things and say things
that may offend people I know about show
business oh no but your tweets are
usually really funny I try to be funny a
lot of the time but other times i do
like I you know same thing you do
something seriously [ __ ] like a pillar
really [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah you know like
and I don't know I mean what else am I
people get really mad at me about my
political tsp I like that by the way
because i was reading it wasn't on
twitter but I I checked out your
Facebook fan page and I loved it and I
hope you can talk about this if not
we'll edit out but you went after and I
love this and I love Kindler for this I
love you for this you went after [ __ ]
i think it was Damon Damon wins and like
somebody else and dennis miller and guys
low oh yeah and what was what were you
going after them where their work
comedians and community yeah job is to
like exposed upon society and and to
point out [ __ ] that's wrong it's it's
not our job to to punch down and anke
make fun of rape victims or people who
are paying more and all the way I saw
Dave Chappelle in Montreal and he came
on stage and goes you know who I don't
like this is how he came on you know who
I don't like fat people Oh shucks is
agent Bell that's the kind of shot [ __ ]
but that's where you go you're so rich
now that you are you're part of it
you're actually making fun now they're
part of the things you'd be making fun
of so they've lost touch with you know
what I loud the guys the guys and I'll
give you a couple of names maybe you
heard of them who stay true no matter
how much money they have Richard Pryor
George Carlin yes those [ __ ] guys
yeah stayed relevant be and staying
relevant to me just means that you stay
fighting the powers fighting at people
who have real power not the [ __ ]
powerless the fact the fact that anyone
because I I was at the improv like two
or three months ago on the show on a
Saturday and Damon Wayans dropped induce
oh this is where you saw him and what
did he say and he's almost half of his
act was about magic Johnson having AIDS
and how it was funny Wow hilarious that
he had AIDS Wow and it just went on and
on and you're like who like who is this
for why by the way that sounds like
something from 1980 first of all and do
you see what i mean by staying relevant
totally guy who's talking about that has
nothing to say nothing about the
military the masters of war who rule are
[ __ ] society where you going down why
do you go you see that it does people
don't like to talk about the real seats
of power I you know I try to do it now
you know what I do like I come on stage
and I go and in this offense of
comedians like I'll come on stage the
Dory this show and I'll go folks I just
want to tell you I won't be talking
about funny cookies because there are
currently a million people fleeing wars
around the globe even though I do think
it's hilarious when raising shrivel I I
have got on stage and said I'm sorry I'm
probably not going to talk about ghosts
or watermelons because I watch these
people talk about that only what are you
doing right I just don't give a [ __ ] I
think but I feel something where of an
age where were you watching younger
comedians and we're just like who gives
a [ __ ] what are you saying dad talk
about something talk about anything that
is true too when I was a younger
comedian I just thought it was such a
feat to get on stage yeah like I was
like this this would be me like oh my
god
I just hope funny s and then I would get
up there and i would i would just you
know this shouting personality that i
have was really out of control when i
was younger like a like at least its
focus now on something dear when i was
younger i would just go out ago my
father is a piece of [ __ ] wait you still
do that well you know when i call him he
may anders me you know when i call my
dad he still blames me for everything in
his life no my mom did that the other
day called her a koala match I think I
haven't called heard ages cuz she called
him she goes I want you to know that you
made me depressed I'm like what the [ __ ]
just happened really yeah it was crazy I
was like this is insane when I call my
dad I was calling kind of regularly he's
like oh oh look who it is like like I
and he never calls me by the way so he's
like oh this is great my son is yeah my
son and I'm just like and immediately
I'm like okay uh just give out love the
books you just put together they said
you give out love ya host again let's be
a be a be an emotional warrior and
that's just giving out love and not
being defensive or angry yeah right I'm
so anyway you went after lands and who
know of Dennis Miller well Dennis
Phillips in mind in 911 but he's just
one of those guys that just punching up
they didn't have the I mean their part
their punch up there is punching down
there was punching down yeah and they're
just there's just too many [ __ ]
idiots like that right and it is true
though that we watch younger comedians
and most of them don't have anything to
really say that very interesting not for
me and there and they're very successful
ya know but you know the guys I always
enjoyed the bill yes is that I grew up
watching they said something and I feel
like they've just been this change where
you're extremely rewarded for not saying
anything anymore that is coming Lulu
dude alternative rooms are now I would
say more hack than comedy clubs Wow is
it is that you fell I think so I I just
think there's I just think they're just
oh yeah at all empty yes the alternative
rooms now have the guys who are like
just like like it's all personality and
like yeah and you know who I get really
mad at man mark not only I am a little
mad at merit but I different reasons but
they get mad at the comics who do that
vapid [ __ ] but the audiences to me
they're so easily entered well they're
trained right they're trained that's why
i get mad at the comics because i feel
like the comics are training them to me
yeah [ __ ] idiots so is there an itch
i think there is a niche for people like
us who have something to say hi mean who
knows I may think that it I mean it is
heavy you have a much smaller audience
and no one cares drivin surely no one
wants you on TV why the [ __ ] is though I
don't know it's late to me it's Larry's
the Booker's of all the late shows are
all like we love his comedy we want we
wanted to do a show and then set after
said I'd give my own no that's not
that's not [ __ ] well that's my comedy I
know you're late show he's my comma
delay chose can suck my dick that would
be great hahahahaha no i mean because i
find that true in like uh I had
Fitzsimmons on and I wanted to go after
uh fallon greg fitzsimmons and he goes
Jimmy is it's a good friend no I so that
that conversation started there but he
is a perfect example Fallon not fit
sermon Fallon is a perfect example of
like that [ __ ] he is the spokesperson
for backbeat holes he could not be more
vapid he's never it once in his entire
career I think said anything of
substance yes can anyone think of
anything no and he's like like there's
you know there's [ __ ] the world of
the ecosystems being destroyed he's like
let's throw a hot dog through
hole with our guest today Scarlett
Johansson Scarlett get over and the
roots the biggest sellouts ever the
ethnic roots let's have some hot dog
music and that's late night in a nut job
will it be interesting to see colbert
but Colbert has already said more in his
week on the air there about anything
then Fallon has his letter well it's
interesting because Colbert has
inherited the Letterman legacy and
Letterman was the only one who kind of
had anything to say Letterman was just a
cynical prick of a guy and so Colbert
gets to go into that slot where is the
tonight show well it was destroyed by
Leno this is rylann Otto from Carson to
leno is there a greater drop in quality
in the history of television and you
know and that's a great point that's a
great point to go from course until Leno
and it's kinda it kind of represents the
dumbing down Oh of the Holy whole
[ __ ] country I had a friend who
worked in it as an executive at NBC and
one day really they called her in and
they said hey we want you to watch leno
for two weeks just go down and watch it
and then give us back notes on what you
think and so she goes cool person this
is yet yeah and this is years into Leno
and she does it and she comes back and
sits down she goes it's just awful it's
awful it's just she reported the truth
yeah it's just low-rent nonsense and
it's terrible and the head of whatever
department this was just silent yeah
that's what we thought like they were
just all so sad but they were stuck with
it they were just all 8 customer ratings
are good yeah the ratings are good but
it's just garbage like they knew that
they were ruining something precious and
they just couldn't stop it there's just
like a runaway idiot train
but by the way yeah uber had a thing
yesterday did you see this no what is it
between i think it was like five and ten
p.m. yeah that's interesting because i
took leno after 10 yeah was gonna be
driving an uber for five hours in
disguise and you could get picked up by
leno and i read that and i was like i
should just take it over for five hours
because i would love to just get in that
car and how does it feel to have
destroyed an iconic television show
what's it like to ruin greatness he
would be destroyed because the
interesting thing about guys like that i
think is that they know it he knows it
you know what i mean and everybody says
this and i think it was kind of true
that leno at one point was a pretty good
stand-up he was a great standup i
remember watching he was so dark and
weird when he came on Letterman one time
I was watching letterman in the very
early days and he came out and he had
this just kid covered in dirt and rags
with him with him and and Dave's like
what who is this and he goes that's my
street urchin oh he just had this dirty
little kid with him tell you mistreat
urchin and that polenta was he was just
dark and weird and then he turned into
whatever he turned in in milquetoast he
turned into the corporate yeah
spokesperson for comedy which a lot of
comedy is it's like don't don't talk
about this don't go right out that you
know what I mean it's [ __ ] it sucked
and I don't know and it's an interesting
comment at the altar wombs the
alternative rooms have become even more
[ __ ] in the vapid weather way they're
way more sensitive to a really deep
personal material they get really weird
it's almost like a college audience like
highly politically correct but not
really right what do you think of San
Francisco audiences I just performed up
there I don't know me and they'd be like
that yeah forshay can be like that right
sure they get weirded out by
like it's funny cuz whenever I do
anything like I said all the migrants
are using the people fleeing you know
all these wars that we've created um all
these words that we started you know
coming and they're using the Waze app
and it's [ __ ] them I got a lotta I
got a lot of [ __ ] but there were like oh
I heard this and I and you get this from
like that the politically and and you
know what like it'sit's it confuses me a
little bit the political correctness
argument because I don't want to be up
there talking about how fat people suck
right but they do but yeah hey hey you
know well no it's true you don't want to
sit there talking about it but and for
some reason that's more palatable than
talking about something right like race
or anything else they get ho what's
going on um I can't talk about race for
some reason I feel like I just I don't
have any like I can't talk about it like
who talks about race in a good way
that's white comic right I don't know I
inside it's a really we have you ever do
it bill burr does and he does it pretty
well he does Jim Norton does it I don't
know if he does it well yeah I don't
know if he does it well either Evan see
you know who I was listening to oh my
god I can't believe he's a funny dude
because I was laughing during his
podcast but if there's a more right-wing
racist I Apolo Oh have you ever and he's
funny so he guided draw Jimmy's like
he's got a funny voice like hey you know
Oh de Blasio the mayor of New York right
yeah yep what a douche bag this guy did
I don't know he's just a ranger he's a
[ __ ] right wing more room yeah he's a
total idiot just a hundred percent idiot
he's always been a [ __ ] idiot forever
he's always been i got funny like he's
an idiot yeah only whereas most of the
right wing
it's comedians are not fun are not funny
so it's a beautiful combination because
you're like okay we you know that's good
I love when someone like fox or whoever
tries to do a comedy sketch is just man
it's just so much I'm shaloo is on Fox
all the time and I'm like what do you
owe to see the red our thing yes I don't
think that's I think that's just talked
to Andy Levy who is over there and he
they're just sort of totally independent
from Fox all ok like they don't get paid
attention to and they just have
comedians on yeah so it's not like the
usual regurgitation of nonsense Tom's
funny yeah he's a nice guy too yeah he
is funny yeah yeah but I've seen him on
Fox before and I'm like what what the
[ __ ] is at well that let me tell you
something if you see him on Fox you
should be in bed because you're up too
late cuz that's when he's on boy I fall
asleep lately what time you go to bed
well it used to be two three yeah 22 now
it's like sometimes I just start you
know me and the wife we have on Poirot
huh the Agatha do you know Poirot the
Agatha Christie character I'm not that
old yet you know that is a funny thing
because I did mention that at a club I
said folks it's really crazy me and my
wife we're just watching Poirot and you
know around eight or nine and our
neighbors just sound like they're
[ __ ] on coke and I just think it's a
funny juxtaposition like we're watching
this quiet quiet Agatha Christie a very
genteel detective story and next door
they're just banging the walls [ __ ]
on Cogan it's just a great juxtaposition
that's what you get in apartments like
in one apartment you could just have
someone chained to a radiator begging
for their life in a pleasurable way in
the other apartment it's just two people
City sitting on a couch going hey look
Hastings is bringing pretty funny in
this episode honey wait did you then San
Francisco did you get booed I did do
that cuz nobody with what I want to tell
you a radio
what I want is things that people didn't
know who Paro was and did know by now I
don't know really no use Appa you don't
watch PBS it'll it--watch a late age do
you have i watch a little bit of PBS I
watched the the burns documentaries and
I watch everybody loves the night the
burns documentary Downton you do watch
Downton yeah that is an addictive little
show it is yeah I like it you know the
Brits over there don't like it but they
don't know working Klatt world of
working on I remember I was [ __ ]
around and this isn't to hurt you that I
was in London but I was in London and we
were going now it's a lifestyle that my
lifestyle ah anyway I was gone we were
going into Westminster Abbey waiting on
line to go into Westminster at me and I
and I turned to the quote unquote that
guard or the century whatever the [ __ ]
it is over there who was like right
before you go into church and I said
this is Downton Abbey right and he he
goes to me our guide that shape or
something like bear it was in and all I
wouldn't watch that oh my god you know
because it's like a class thing well
they have a lot of they have a lot of
class problems over there it's not we
don't we have to know and we're here
we're very doing in a wealthy class or
your [ __ ] oh you're a [ __ ] animal
yeah that's fine animal America was set
up to be it's all working out don't
worry about it don't look on ya although
all the refugees are streaming out of
Syria that's just the beginning that's
this is the first climate change war and
they're more that are coming and we're
gonna have to put up hold red to put up
emotes are you worried about your kid
because I know I'll be dead before I
think I'm hoping I'll be dead before
this [ __ ] really hits the fan of my dog
like all the people I care about my wife
like I hope and a couple of comics I I
hope everybody will be dead because it's
gonna be brutal what oh I think we'll
see a lot of I think we'll see a lot of
death before we kick off damn it um like
now he's gonna know my kid's gonna see
just object horror its life it's that's
what Fitzsimmons said I said do you
worry about your kid and Greg said I see
my kid fleeing things
ah yeah i think my I think well Gary
though and no I think it's courageous to
have a kid like I just would be worrying
constantly I came in I guess I'm just
it's just like well you know it's his
path we'll see what happens yeah yeah
you know we do we do live in an empire
with all the all of all the guns so at
the end of the day we're not going to be
that bad off but you're gonna see like
people streaming out of Bangladesh
because there's no more Bangladesh you
know like that's what about the climate
stuff here like I mean when da when does
California become unlivable because DG I
was up there by the way I was up in San
Francisco again not to break this kind
of lifestyle I've readied right now I've
already talked about London San
Francisco but I was up in San Francisco
and one of the comics up there just goes
to me nado nado green he goes to me too
dear about the fires and I'm like what I
just got that was the tears that was the
tonys we were in the green room believe
his last name is green as well too with
I doesn't matter he doesn't sound like
an important process he's good he's
gonna like me well what he talked about
though is she talking about like no no
he's a union leader Bubba by now he goes
huh you're about the fires I know what
about 100 miles from here lake county is
[ __ ] but I mean is huge ya know it's
like a it's like someone dropped a nuke
at this point in California right and
the drought Alex Gramma's dam and the
drought here Wow you know I studied I
studied earth science oh you did yeah
what so what's going on here exactly
you're the first experts dad exactly
what i learned would happen in college
in 1994 this is exactly what we were
taught when that arrangers won the cup
there would be yeah i mean that's what
I'm talking about mm-hmm didn't they win
it they won that's it what about like
Messier wasn't on that yeah that was the
Messier team 1994 it was that long that
was the last year I celebrated big time
in hockey at six 6 plus
teen it's been 21 years and we've been
good the last couple of years that's
almost worse than climate change
definitely of I'm a Kings fan so oh just
good and they beat the Rangers the
Rangers that was fun oh [ __ ] they did
not that was a good series it depends
are you a big hockey fan yeah pretty big
oh cool yeah a lot of lot of people are
not hockey fan no it's not a big in LA
no but they have a rabid fan base here
because I don't come with King games and
they're like they're into it yeah they
did fans good fans are the best fans in
la I'd say yeah yeah of all the distant
basketball the basketball is are you a
laker guy no I don't like mba oh yeah I
did why by the way but you're a big
baseball guy and I love the Yankees and
you love the Giants yes and then
football who do you like I don't watch
football okay you're better than me then
because because i think you know like I
rail against the corporate state but i
still have my sports addictions like
that's how I zone out like I love the
Yankees I love the Giants in football
which is just no that's gotta be
horrible I mean your best times were
Phil Simms oh so painful I adopt
watching football why Raiders nope
because ramps when Fox took over the NFL
okay they put commercials in after
kickoffs and they put commercials in
everywhere they could and the games just
dude I don't get longer I just yeah I
right it's like [ __ ] this i don't know
write this [ __ ] anymore you mad and
there was one game where they tried
sound effects do you remember that yes
they for a half a game and then they
stopped his bail out they tried out i
can sound it was like I was a glove [ __ ]
is happening right mean it into a video
I was insane literally yeah like a lot
of Hollywood movies have become video
games like the whole genre of
transformers there there's a lot of
video game movies out there are well
there's actually a new movie coming out
that is shot exactly like a first-person
shooter video thing it's just you just
see the guy's hands shooting and i watch
the trailer and I was like why would you
watch one two three
this is just nauseating this is what
they're [ __ ] doing yeah you know yeah
it's just yeah and then you got the
little into indie films where it's like
look I just want to go to Nebraska with
you so why don't they have something in
the middle like a decent movie a decent
movie in the middle hey I'm gonna make a
movie but going into braska right but
what do you want it to be about wow it's
about going to Nebraska I know but well
he's gonna be with his dad what does
that mean no here's here's the clincher
his dog it's going to Nebraska in the
winter oh oh here's some employs a pile
of money hahaha and it's gonna be in
black and white you can make it more
boring so here's what and it's gonna
have Bruce Dern in it yeah and he's
really good and he's an icon uh-huh so
it's just all about that kind of feeling
my oh look a deal Bruce done in Nebraska
actually that wasn't too bad a movie it
wasn't too bad but let's face it you
also wasn't too good I agree with that
but it is the antidote to like or the
the polar extreme of that [ __ ] like
transformers I can't even think of
another movie but will that get most of
the Pacific Rim it's all that Pacific
Rim if you're talking about the porn
movie was terrific that was a terrific
that was a porn will be done with your
attention to detail your thinking of
pacific rimmed oh yes my mistake and by
the way folks i am just kidding that so
back to ya planet Earth this is exactly
what we were taught a 1994 would howl
right with California is that there
would be extreme swings you because now
the floods are coming next but it was
people in the droughts it would be
droughts extremely extreme heat extreme
droughts a
lack of snow followed by torrential
horrible rains when you don't I mean
it's tough for me you live in a while
you do you live in a valley hmm okay we
moved all the mountains you what we
moved up to the mound you is it in la
crescenta yeah for one other one of the
main reasons I want to get out of here
is cuz shit's gonna get weird I so being
in the mountains is kind of a little
safer yeah that's cool yeah do you have
like like roads and like you know like I
have a lot of long-range guns I have it
honey I cannot man the tower right now I
have to do the dollop which you know has
a lot of preparation fan have you been
messing with my mortars a lot of that so
so extreme weather explain we're in it
now it's extreme weather but there's
something happening that no one
predicted and that's that the ocean has
increased in temperature five degrees
off because California which is just a
what the [ __ ] gonna happen no one
knows what's gonna happen they don't you
know here's what here's what I czar and
my science is about as good as my comedy
here's what I have heard that there
there's two camps about their supposedly
an El Nino coming but there there is
there is may not happen there's
definitely no me you're coming I've
definitely i read i realize there are
but whether cuz we're taking you do we
yeah I my Creed and I've check about all
the signs justified tell me that because
someone was saying because of the heat
there's something have you heard this
term and not from a Steve McQueen movie
but the blob they're calling it the blob
of that may stop the elny well that's
what they're talking about with the five
be there anytime I the resistant Ridge
are they talking about that yes a ridge
of the boys just enriching by the waves
out there hold on you [ __ ] I want
talking to you not Dave we are talking
about weather resistant Ridge the blob
this is all very dear to us in
California we are on the verge of
extinction right now Northern
California's ablaze in Southern
California I could barely move every day
it's 100 degrees glad David out there
starfish are dying so uh so there's the
resistant ridge which is this Ridge that
keeps forming every winter in right off
of California and sends the jet stream
up over California and then down and
that's why the East Coast getting
slammed with snow that's supposed to be
our rain is that right yeah what they're
getting is should have been ours in the
past so they're getting hit with it now
directly where is it supposed to come in
and then you know slowly dissipate over
the country so there's a big like just
just think it was just like a big
barrier out there but it's gone right
it's gone away right now and it doesn't
look like it's going to come back that's
what it looks like but is it associated
with that five degree increase in
temperature of water and no one knows
what's going to happen because i have
five days a total [ __ ] disaster no
one knows what's gonna happen the
scientist well they must speculator let
me just say this every single model that
people have come up with it's nowhere
near as bad as what's happening that all
of their worst case scenarios are being
far surpassed by reality every single
[ __ ] model they're like holy [ __ ]
it's so much worse than they thought it
would be it's just it's just off which
is hard to do we go make models usually
like go to like like well let's say if
this [ __ ] happened yeah it's it's
like Oh every single model like it's so
much worse I can't believe it now here's
the thing wait let's say it rains like a
[ __ ] ok it's terrible in in what I
just think it happens around november
october no he it's supposed to start at
late january when the rain season starts
and closing right southern california
will it be here late january that's when
El Nino supposed to hit ya what will the
weather like it's so funny but I'm askin
you like Jax but because you studied
earth science but you think it'll be hot
as [ __ ] between now and December no
it'll it'll cool down um but you know
the it's just gotten really weird look
with El Nino we're getting all that
humid all of the all of the hurricanes
that are happening are than breaking up
and like that's what happened yesterday
we got here her
Cain ran from a leftover Helen was her
name she perished out over this did you
get a lot of rain because you're up in
the mountain rain oh I think that oh you
live in a better place because Valley
got we got like some rain not much yeah
no Ranger it rain for ya rim good it was
nice that's nice right yeah isn't it
like the rest i feel like we're okies
out here but instead of talking about
the crops failing we just talked about
bands like like we're just in the same
like like it's like the Dust Bowl out
here but we're just all talking about
bands instead of like you know there's
there's no crops it's I'll I am
terrified if it's coming this winter hmm
it's gonna be because over in the
mountains now this yeah it's a concern
well the houses just go to me it's like
for me it's fun because I like to stand
at the bottom of Mulholland and just
watching the houses come down from
Mulholland and just be like with the
cigarette going baby that's the guy who
have produced a Bonnie and Clyde films
that was his house like it's kind of fun
out here in LA to like name the houses
like it's usually some producers yeah
babies yeah but then when the earthquake
happens they said they sit up in the
mountain which doesn't shake as much and
they looked out of the valley and they
go look at the poor people shaking above
hahaha no no no that I disagree that's I
think every day they are like look at
the poor people scuttling about but the
earthquakes I heard it [ __ ] up the
mountain no no the oh I and you get a
lot of liquification in in our area
because a lot of it's been built in and
and liquification moves it moves more
the the lower parts move more cuz meal
yeah yeah because the mountains I was in
only one earthquake out here being in
New Yorker I'd never experienced it and
I was living at fountain and vine again
not to hurt anybody come at anybody
that's a weird brag I gotta be hahahaha
I mean I get it I live in the mountains
I don't live in the heart of everything
I get it found the vines if I mean
that's it that's the spot you know it
was I live there for people who haven't
been
and by you're missing a lot you really
are it's I don't know how to describe it
but if you've read The Great Gatsby it's
nothing like that it's it's it's just I
mean it's hard to put out a half a block
away there is a dollar Chinese food
store that I don't know if you've ever
had I just you ever had a dollar yes
with the domain no there I don't know
but oh my god a [ __ ] out of me I ate in
there I think twice and she go to the
hospital almost it should be called
dysentery 'he's almost because there is
a doctor there in the front like they do
provide would that be funny if a
restaurant is so bad there is a standing
dr. like they have to have a doctor and
they have a at the soda and instead of
thought they just have one for pepto
they have yeah you get pepto but you
know they have like just a guy standing
with the needle it's almost like getting
bitten by a snake when you eat that food
it's like we will give you the injection
people would always be in there eating I
could never understand it because it's a
dollar I know but you know like how bad
money wouldn't you rather die I I would
yeah yeah yeah I mean if I'm been good
lately you know cuz I'm what's good
little money why eat a lot of a lot of
organic veggies and stuff so organic
like I can shop even though I feel like
such an idiot shopping at Whole Foods
why it's better because dude when I go
up with me my wife when we go up with a
shopping cart and it's two hundred and
eighty dollars okay we're 225 go with
$225 take off this is a long way I'm
done that's crazy you don't show you
when you go to Whole Foods it sounds
like you just get a couple of the ghetto
we get every bite do you eat it already
throw I wind up throwing it
some of this stuff like you know you
know like to me to me when I go shopping
I get all kinds of excited about oh look
at this thing and look at cuz I'm a baby
I'm quadra like look at that holy Shi so
I go crazy for like like like yeah they
have all these fake meats Oh God fake
meats and I mean dangerous out I don't
like the Fate fake by age 18 just just a
world of you just hear the words and you
salivate hmm fake meat I uh what and now
are you a vegan for health reasons or
would you eat the know it's coming
factory meet it it's for like the animal
stuff okay so they don't really know so
then reitman of them so then you would
eat the factory me that's coming oh you
know that is a debate you mean that they
produce like meat in a lamp yeah right
so it's just I just I rose by the way
that sounds just as bad as the dollar
they wish and sounds worse how about
this had a ball game here in this in a
bowl game lab me like a guy walking up
and down the aisles lat me laugh eat get
your fresh lab me hahahaha just came out
of the lab Monsanto me oh just widows
[ __ ] how great would it be if
now doesn't it laughs the lab meet all
of a sudden started evolving they came
they came in one day and just a couple
of feet were hanging off one like we got
to take a lockdown couple this is the
other ones have four feet see and then
somebody's talking in this trio here's
the site as a side this is Bob the left
meets the lab meet has gotten very smart
no one of the burgers just asked me for
a cigarette
Bob I caught the lab meet reading a
Dickens novel and now the lab mate is
reading great expectations and then
there's a lab meet breakout birthday
they knock down the doors and the meat
escapes then we have to fight for
control I that's what I'm hoping for
anyway that's my movie I don't know at
least I'm on the right side of that
because no jit yeah because I really you
are actually yeah that's huge because
and not like guilt in anybody out about
the treatment animals but they are
[ __ ] knocking down the rainforest to
graze cattle I do great it's true it's
true though but that's the lungs of the
earth not again to brag that I know what
the lungs of the earth are that long
haha I start I don't know what I'm the
guy who doesn't know what bragging is
look I look I volcanoes to the eyes of
you know it's no it's terrible it's the
were the worst thing that you can the
worse the planet the worst thing that's
drawing the planet is red meat that's
the worst thing that's that's it if you
want to say that benefit and if you give
a [ __ ] at all about the treatment of
these [ __ ] pork right well that I
don't hey nobody is one of the idea of
HIV no they can't move that has enormous
roses and love that is [ __ ] riffic
right that's it I I it is her if I would
like when I ate a breast of chicken to
have a picture of that chicken there
with its feet groaning yeah sure you're
in a household where you like you're
like sweetheart can you put on the
slaughterhouse video before we eat you
just put it on the big d HD screen and
turn it up because I want to hear the
screams and I want the kid to hear the
scream so he knows what life is about
hey son did you did you know what chicka
could scream like a human did you hear
that and your kid is just like he's just
like online he's 6 and he's online going
please I don't know who these people are
I just know that I'm not like them I
need help he does take me to six flag
it does that make up for it it doesn't
make up for it there's terrible things
happening but getting back to this
[ __ ] thing man like the apocalyptical
climb out here is crazy and I talk to
people in London do you know like they
have a great climate in England they
wouldn't say so they think it rains too
much oh I know they do and it's just so
temperate their summer dude they think
it's unbearably hot at 80 well there
that what they're gonna be hit hard okay
yeah that Jets I don't know that makes
me a little happy Jets William thing is
gonna warm them up the shoot [ __ ]
crazy when will this happen so if if
that resilient rating keeps happening
yeah in England [ __ ] wow you really know
you whether I do yeah okay let's talk a
little bit now about ghosts no better
that is funny you know the dumbing down
like they still have that [ __ ] show
ghost hunters félicité still on I
remember today Hawaii Wyatt whoa a guy
who I used to be buddies with he's such
a good guy too once the wild drop me a
note but like he [ __ ] got a job on I
think it's ghost hunters yeah is that
the name of the show I thinks and they
kept him employed for years because
season FTC's just won't stop there I
watched it once because at first you
like yeah I don't that you because
here's the whole up you go in with an
open mind no no here's the whole appeal
it ghost-like boy life is boring mmm
maybe there are ghosts that's totally
what it is it's totally what is it's
like that's behind a lot of [ __ ] like
that you know a behind a lot of like
Aunt the alien thing to would people
yeah there's definitely you know who the
people who believe in UFOs these are the
people who like every day like they're
just staring at bugs on their porch wish
that someone would kill them that you
don't work and they look at the computer
screen into their day dead entering of
god I wish I was driving home someone
would just pick me up from here and just
put something in my ass menial dead-end
jobs are [ __ ] breeding ground for
people who believe in ghosts and aliens
but anyway and there's a lot of those
jobs but yeah
so when I want to talk about is your
podcast tell me about the dollar alright
the dollop is yeah because I hear it's
really good yeah it's [ __ ] hurt uh so
I by its American to its American
history so I that's cool I find a story
you would imagine history buff yeah I'm
like I like history a lot so and I'm I
have a viable the basically what
happened was I was like I spent so much
time on the internet just reading crazy
weird stories and stuff that I was like
well why don't I do something with this
what were you reading jet I just any
crazy sites i could just go to stuff
when I find him a couple because I I go
on the internet and I'm just I just go
to the same for things and I never
[ __ ] expand there's a great there's a
great site that has like just one page
crazy things called my knowledge nuts oh
yeah it's yeah it's great it just got
tons and it's just one of things I just
keep just keep going through like Joe my
god it's just like more crazy facts it
there nine facts they're just like a
nice but it's just some guy spinning
just a guy screaming no it's just uh
it's just a like really brief synopsis
of a story that happened at some point
okay and it's great and that got you was
that the thing that got you into dolla
well the dollop so I I did walk in the
room and I got so [ __ ] tired of
talking about myself every week I just
got it I don't want to hear me anymore
and that is hard it really I never four
years after four years I mean if you
I've urine healthy for years yeah but if
you're a healthy person yeah so you
won't have this happening but if you're
healthy person starts to get weird
luckily mental health is not one by the
way I heard are you still looking for a
psychologist cuz my wife is a
psychologist she can find you one yeah
she can get you a name thank you always
Dana referred me to someone Dana Gould
oh god no not Dave look don't take
advice from and this guy celebrities in
Beverly I don't want to travel a lot I
want to find someone in the valley by
the way if you're a shrink out there in
the valley and you take insurance also
this guy to take insurance a lot of them
don't ya I can't afford it i care is
that bad well 150 like my wanted a
hundred fifty cash
Oh cash out nobody's 50 would that be
funny and that's on a bad shoes like
like i'm talking about and then I was
molested by my uncle Ned that's gonna be
another for an hour that's cash look I
said if it gets into molestation it's a
no-no but a lot don't take insurance I
don't blame ya they don't cuz the
insurance companies are [ __ ]
nightmares oh boy you don't have to tell
me that man by the way that alone should
be [ __ ] basis for revolution and yeah
country I totally agree corporate they
are just like [ __ ] you yeah they
basically that's what they're doing like
[ __ ] you yeah we're not playing you and
we're gonna make it so hard for you like
I by the way whatever whatever corporate
problem i'm having i have [ __ ]
DirecTV now I used to have time when I
got rid of them now I have a direct TV
when I have to call them I cry I'm not
kidding dude just the corporate phone
tree I wind up in Malaysia Guam Sri
Lanka nowhere near la yeah and they're
like Sir sir we have to add the $45
charge freakoid ideas yeah a deal wit
they know it's insane and insurance
companies are just like other monsters
well my wife you know she does take
insurance but she will have to Bill four
times five times because they will just
reject it and then they'll go oh sorry
that was a mistake they're just [ __ ]
they it's a strategy it is a strategy
they'll hope you'll give up absolute
that's all that and so they're doing
that with the doctors so why here's my
people mental health exercise eat well
don't eat processed sugar and flour I'm
on this kicked ugly I haven't done it
for 24 days I a man eating sugar or
flour for 20 how's that once you're past
your past like the two weeks off sugar
it's great I feel pretty good are you a
good are you good with not eating too
much sugar no i i went 82 years of that
sugar and then oh I know I I went a year
and then snapped it feels great when
you're off sugar though it'll feel
terrific totally but I can't see myself
doing it at least not to my kids all
I mean he goes I guess a ped am i coming
all [ __ ] thing attempt dance like
that's what kids do you that you just
you go okay he's gone what can I do my
work in like like you need a release
yeah you need a release yet and if I'm
not gonna do heroin all each now I know
Tim's what the [ __ ] are they Oh Aaron
nosam it's the greatest what I've in the
world what are they it's an Australian
okay knew what it wasn't us yeah I think
you can get him here now yeah right
target well okay okay so it's a just
look just like the basic Tim Tam is just
a chocolate-covered like sort of cookie
thing right and it's so good you can't
believe what's happening but then they
have a multitude of flavors they have
caramel they have sea salt with by the
way normal and Cecil [ __ ] really float
my boat like when I'm eating a caramel
sea salt cookie yeah I just don't care
about all the wars anyway it's like oh
nothing else matters who gives a [ __ ]
about the planet at that point which is
by the way the function of all this
sugar and [ __ ] in our diet it's like
don't worry about all the people are
suffering and your impending doom we
have Tintin yeah then no and they're
right it is a [ __ ] though oh if you go
eat a whole thing do you eat like like
if you if you that is the [ __ ] about
sugar like is to calm down like it's so
great it's like such a it hits that that
part of your brain that is similar
heroin that sugar [ __ ] rush and
you're like yes but then i get i notice
i'm angry about 20 minutes later totally
like holy wish I agree yeah it makes you
angry I'm like like my wife will say
something beyond what what she's like
you hahahahaha wait Tim told you I'd any
tipton did you have 10 tabs are you just
reflecting on your childhood it's hard
to tell so hard to tell what about when
you're eating tim tams reflecting in her
childhood that's
but that's that's the cycle you reflect
in each other that's right not in bygone
it just keeps going on but talk about
the doubtfully we have five ok so the
Diamonds left folks five minute mark so
what happens is i find sort of an
obscure story from american history for
examples are em someone sent andrew
jackson a giant giant giant wheel of
cheese that he kept in the White House
for years and then when he left the
White House he had a party and I one
came and ate it there was a guy named FD
now you'll base the podcast around that
that'll be like all podcasts citable
taught would you have a guest about that
story yeah so that's what I do I read it
to Gareth Reynolds is a really funny
comedian with Karen he's so [ __ ]
funny Reynolds yeah he's a British he
well he's his parents are British uh so
he's really funny so I just read in the
store and he's never heard it so he's
just reacting to it and they're all
insane stories so it's he's just wounded
warrior yeah he's a really funny improv
guys so he just goes off on it and riots
it's really fun so it's you and Gareth
yeah oh cool and then we do live ones we
have live one will will have a guest
what was your favorite one so far that
yet that you would recommend like if
people wanted to get a taste of the
dollop the rube yeah aaron says the rube
the roof the roof the rube was a
baseball player in the round Bob Rubin
and comedian so pop written but a rube
is a yeah a base of play around 1900 and
even if you don't like baseball it is
completely insane literally okay the
room yeah the route so the dollop that's
like the one everyone I think likes the
best yeah through so Dave thanks man for
coming on do you want to plug anything
we could get you at Twitter at Dave
Anthony just like it's spelled you know
um anything else you want no just the
dollop is it's gone up next Thursday
right or this Thursday and it's gonna be
next thursday yeah I don't think I have
anything it all up in at Dave Anthony
I'm kind of voice Merrin coming back
yeah no yeah it looks like we're coming
back nice so you'll be bad hasn't been
announced but it looks good yeah you
having fun on the show maybe we'll bring
it back again no I oh I don't know ask
you this what did you think when you got
the call that we were
back on the show I loved it because I I
said mark no because when when Mark
killed me on when Mark when you guys
whoever killed me off first season yeah
I go to marin because i was like as I oh
great so you killed me like I was in
some club with the more I was going
great you kill me off man yeah first
season and I was like that's great and
then I go look did you could bring me
back i actually said you could bring me
back as it goes you said that I said
that to him you know because I'm
thinking Marin's one of the few a few
people who actually have me on that show
and sure enough it happened that was
nice you're and you almost called me
back again last season but it didn't
happen where because you heard about an
item where a guy was being seen yeah
like what was that like someone was
seeing a clown Riley the clown I wanted
you to be the clown [ __ ] yes yeah the
clown was in the season finally I tried
to get the clown in for three years
funny man i got the clowning by cool um
so please follow Dave Anthony at Dave
Anthony his podcast the dollop and
you're on all things comedy network too
yeah um and that's it and rate this
podcast on iTunes if you can five stars
let me know what you think of the show
email me at e Pepitone @ sbcglobal.net
thanks and we will see you next week
everybody I love you love you too
you